sciences
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette absence
aujourd'hui consacré aux chez nous mon
corps vous aurez certainement remarqué
que plusieurs de nos vidéos traite de
l'évolution de l'homme mais que nous
n'avons pas beaucoup parlé de fossiles
d'hommes préhistoriques
il est donc grand temps de réparer cette
erreur
attention ça va être rapide
voyez vous apprécierez la qualité de nos
effets spéciaux envoyez nous des sous et
10 ans et était sûre pour le faire et
j'attends ça marche toujours
bon hein soyons un peu sérieux depuis
longtemps les scientifiques ont compris
que l'homme avait un ancêtre parmi les
grands singes et ce bien avant qu'on ne
se rende compte de l'existence de
fossiles d'hominidés le premier fossile
découvert était une calotte crânienne
d'un homme de néandertal
c'est vraiment grand chose ou lit mais
ça peut déjà nous donner des tas
d'informations les placements réseau non
sans l'aide de faux cils mais oui il ya
pléthore indices disséminés partout dans
notre présent qui témoigne de notre
ascendance signait ce cas il suffit de
mener l'enquêté
déjà en question du côté du miroir
vous vous êtes sûrement déjà regarder
dans la glace en faisant des pas de
grimaces mais saviez vous que toutes ces
climats c'est toutes nos expressions
faciales compliqués sont typiques des
primates et whissell nous autres les
singes avant la musculature faciale
appropriée à ce type d'expression pas
toujours très subtil continuons avec le
très classique pouce opposable tellement
pratique que quand on utilise on
oublierait presque qu'il servait avant
tout à vivre dans les arbres est la
chose la plus importante celle qui ne
peut s'expliquer autrement que par une
origine commune avec le chimpanzé plus
de 96% de notre code génétique est
identique à celui du chimpanzé mais
j'aime c'est la vie le plan de
fabrication d'un être vivant sans mode
d'emploi et son annuel d'entretien et il
me semble ans aussi évidente de cette
structure fondamentale ne peut que
témoigner d'une parenté nous sommes si
proches génétiquement des chimpanzés
qu'on a même un certain temps pensé que
l'espèce humaine en faisait partie
intégrante au même titre que les bonobos
ou les chimpanzés commun une sorte de
troisième espèce de chien brothers
si tel est le cas alors nos espèces
devrait pouvoir s'hybrider certes mais
c'est pas si simple que ça tout est une
affaire de chromosomes les chromosomes
sont les structures microscopiques à
l'intérieur de nos cellules qui
contiennent notre code génétique
il se promène toujours par faire comme
des amoureux bon comme c'est mignon 22
paires au total plus une paire de
chromosomes qui détermine le sexe
par contre dans le spermatozoïde et
l'ovule
les paires de chromosomes sont séparées
comme ça quand la lfh échos de l'autre
les deux lots de chromosomes retrouve
une moitié qui leur correspond et
ensemble ils donnent naissance à un
petit bout de chou weight y dément
ça c'était chez l'homme
maintenant chez le chimpanzé il y à un
pic notre code génétique est le leur
sont certes très similaire mais le leur
n'est pas répartie sur 22 paires de
chromosomes comme nous il en a 23 en
fait l'équivalent de notre chromosomes
de est divisée en deux chromosomes plus
petit chez les chimpanzés et c'est toute
petite différence change tout car si
vous fait se rencontrer un spermatozoïde
et d'un ovule de nos deux espèces
le premier fécondera l'autre sans
problème mais au moment de rassembler
les deux autres chromosomes il y aura un
défaut d'appariement un chromosome
restera tout seul dans son coin
et ça ce n'est pas bon du tout pour
l'embryon qui sera immédiatement et
naturellement éliminés enfin bref si on
a cru une période que nous étions déjà
posé c'est bel et bien que nos
différences avec eux sont six mais gris
shon qu'on est à des kilomètres d'avoir
besoin de trouver the chaînon manquant
pour démontrer que l'homme et le
chimpanzé décembre d'un même singes il
d'ailleurs à ce propos de quoi
parle-t-on réellement quand une issue de
chaînon manquant
je veux dire on entend tout le temps les
gens dire chaînon manquant et ça veut
dire quoi
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un chinon montant
cette image très anciennes pour ne pas
dire archaïque de la chaîne évolutive
implique que l'homme est issu d'une
lignée unique dont l'évolution se résume
à une suite d'étapes successibles mérité
est elle seulement aussi simple si tel
est le cas alors n'importe qui serait
capable de me dire à quoi ressemble le
chaînon manquant entre ce carré blanc et
ses carrés noirs
tu vas pas commencer ce document là haut
mettez pas drôle en abord je répond à ta
place
évidemment ça semble tellement facile la
réponse est évident c'est un carré gris
regardons de plus près un cas concret
pour voir si c'est vraiment aussi facile
que ça en a l'air
reprenons être calade de néandertaliens
que nous avions laissé de côté tout à
l'heure elles portent deux gros bourg
n'est au niveau des sourcils qu'on
appelle doré sus orbitaire c'est comme
les bourdes et du ventre mais au dessus
des yeux et en os et en panne grave en
la cambrioler c'était pour les sentes un
caractère présent chez tous les grands
singes il n'a disparu que tardivement
chez l'homme ces caractères et donc
primitif pour notre espèce
par contre l'un courbure de la voûte
crânienne indique clairement un volume
cérébral important estimé à environ 1600
centimètres cube en moyenne soit un
volume de cerveau équivalent sinon
légèrement supérieur à celui de la
plupart des êtres humains modernes un
certain quand on voit certains spécimens
oui bon ne prenons pas non plus dans les
cas extrêmes s'agit de manier n'est
certain pour qui je me demande ce qui se
passe dans leur tête
donc résumons bourrelet sus orbitaire
égale caractère primitif venu cérébrale
important égale caractère dérivés
l'homme de néandertal n'est donc pas
parfait intermédiaire entre l'homme et
les autres grands singes mais un
assortiment de caractère à la fois
primitif et dérivés est encore en nous
n'avons regarder qu'un petit bout de
crâne en regardant tout le squelette
nous ne serions rendu compte que cette
mosaïque de caractère dérivés et
primitif fond de néandertal un véritable
d'allier et non pas un parfait chaînon
manquant intermedia en tout point d'un
gruissan pas eh oui être un chaînon
manquant n'est pas aussi simple que ça
en a l'air
et ça va même plus loin prenons
maintenant l'heure ni thorenc étrange
créature qui pond des oeufs
comme un rétine mais qui allait ensuite
ces petits comme un mammifère
il forme et bien un assemblage de
caractère primitif et dérivés ah oui
il possède aussi un bec de canard des
pattes palmées et une queue de castor
alors avec ça on range ou notre
ornithorynque et bien c'est simple ces
caractères sont des adaptations de cet
animal le milieu aquatique et lui sont
propres ce qui fait de l'ornithorynque
un organisme à part entière à cause de
ses caractéristiques particulières dues
aux modes de vie amphibie
l'ornithorynque ne peut être placée
comme un chaînon manquant sur une ligne
reliant les mammifères reptiles
il ne peut s'agir que d'une branche
divergentes de mammifères s'étant séparé
très tôt durant notre histoire avant que
n'apparaisse le placenta et cela peut
être généralisée à tous les soi-disant
chaînon manquant
comme à l'homme de néandertal qui à
l'espèce humaine ce que l'ornithorynque
et aux mammifères une branche
divergentes mais qui cette fois présente
des caractéristiques qui montre qu'il
sait s'adapter au froid
1 finalement je ne suis plus si sûr que
cette représentation linéaire souhaite
une très bonne idée non c'est certain
notre histoire est un peu plus compliqué
que ça et regarde on dirait qu'il y
avait même des espèces différentes qui
vivait en même temps comme si plusieurs
espèces avait pu vivre à la fois il ya
deux millions d'années par exemple peut
habiter au et 2 7 6 on a à leicester est
homo habilis et il était même accompagné
par une famille d'hommes
aujourd'hui complètement éteinte les
parents trope qu'on appelle aussi
australopithèques robustes 2 millions
d'années c'était il ya longtemps mais à
une chose était encore brial à peine
trente mille ans même à cette époque
très proche de la nôtre
plusieurs espèces d'hommes se
partageaient le monde il y avait l'homme
de néandertal bien sûr et ses cousins
les denisot bien mais il ya aussi les
âmes de fleuriste est certainement déjà
les premiers représentants du peuple de
la cam recèle une espèce très atypique
découverte récemment en chine et pour
vous dire à quel point tout cela n'est
pas bien du tout figurez vous que tout
ce beau monde vivait en même temps que
notre propre espèce homo sapiens sous sa
forme
anatomiquement modernes déjà présentes
en afrique depuis cent mille ans hommes
anatomiquement modernes et
un euphémisme pour dire qu'il s'agit
nous à cette époque homo sapiens paie
d'ailleurs une percée hors d'afrique et
rentrer en contact avec ces espèces
heures que croyez vous qu'il se passe à
la guerre mais une bataille sans pitié a
dû faire rage et après midi dans cette
rue sapiens victorieux ont dû massacrer
sans la renier leurs concurrents et bien
phû de faux figurez vous qu'ils n'ont
pas fait la guerre ils ont fait l'amour
et oui d hybridation entre espèces
d'hommes sont attestés entre homo
sapiens et son cousin néant la pâle
notamment depuis qu'on a découvert une
mâchoire d'hommes de néanderthal muni
d'un petit menton proéminent
en effet ce manteau si caractéristique
est saillant est normalement l'apanage
d'homo sapiens pas de néandertal ce
village de caractère ainsi que la
présence de notre génome de près de 4%
de gênes de néandertaliens démontre que
les longues soirées d'hiver devait être
très très chaude pour parler de glace on
va les voir
des hybridations similaires sont aussi
fortement suspectés entre sapiens et
denisot va ainsi qu'entre denisot va et
néandertal et ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque notre patrimoine génétique garde
la trace de tout un tas l'hybridation
qui ont eu lieu entre les différentes
populations d'hommes qui ont habité en
afrique
bref il ya trente mille ans nous allions
essayer à peu près toutes les
combinaisons possibles
finalement voici la vieille
représentation de l'évolution de l'homme
une belle grosse chaîne bien linéaire
tout comme il faut
et voici la nouvelle allez-y vous pouvez
chercher ce chaînon manquant leur temps
mais si vous tenez tant que ça continue
à voir l'évolution de l'homme comme une
chaîne ma foi j'ai envie de dire que bon
ben c'est votre problème et si ça ne
suffit pas on peut même ajouter qu avant
la découverte de l'amérique par
christophe colomb
les amérindiens et les hommes du vieux
continent étaient restés c'est pareil
depuis presque dix mille ans il ne fait
aucun doute que si cet isolement s'était
prolongée nos deux populations auraient
donné naissance à deux espèces
différentes
le processus était même déjà largement
entamé on a pu le constater quand les
populations inca et aztèques ont été
décimés par la variole et d'autres
maladies du vieux continent et qui
n'existait pas chez eux jusqu'à lors et
oui après dix mille ans de séparation
nous n'étions déjà plus immunisée contre
les mêmes maladies
l'évolution était en marche et et dans
certains coins d'amazonie elle y est
toujours
pour conclure l'histoire de l'être
humain est trop complexe et trop de
huisseau nantes pour être résumée par
une simple chaîne
c'est un arbre dont les ramifications
sont nombreux les dons de nouvelles
branches n'ont pas cessé et ne cesse pas
de se former et s'il n'ya pas réellement
de chaîne alors il ne peut y avoir
réellement de chaînon manquant
simplement des espèces présentes en une
mosaïque de caractère tantôt primitif et
tantôt dérivés l'image de l'évolution de
l'homme sur la forme d'une succession de
maillon est réductrice et cache tout
notre belle diversité une véritable
biodiversité humaine alors luttons
contre la chaîne des lettres préserver
la pièce
cité mais les vivres l'évolution pour
tout savoir sur ce sujet nous vous
recommandons la lecture de ces deux
ouvrages récents et pour tout ce qui est
de trouver des informations fiables de
concernant l'évolution de l'homme sur le
net
nous vous recommandons le site du musée
smithsonian qui est très ludique et
présente un contenu de qualité avec
notamment une galerie de reconstitution
en 3d de crâne de primes actuelles et
fossiles et si vous n'êtes pas familier
avec la langue de shakespeare vous
trouverez à très intéressant contenu sur
le site au midi des points comme et
enfin pour tout connaître de la taille
et et paléontologique et scientifique
vous n'avez qu'à nous rendre une petite
visite sur notre page facebook
merci à tous